now they're telling you your work means
nothing what does mean anything and how
long can a society continue
that doesn't have
meaning
and that doesn't revere work
well there's probably no one in a better
position to answer that question than
mike rowe micro was of course and is now
once again the host of the acclaimed
show dirty jobs he also started a very
successful foundation whose job it is
and successfully does match willing
workers with skilled work mike rowe
joins us now mike thanks so much for
coming on
so
this this stuff is super complicated and
and i hope that we didn't simplify it to
the extent that we distorted what's
happening there's a lot of it that
nobody understands but if you step back
you see the government
disincentivizing work incentivizing
idleness sending the message that
there's no dignity in work there's no
meaning in it why bother what effect
does that have
the effect was encapsulated perfectly in
everything you just said i mean not to
blow smoke or
show too much of my own bias but
that's the greatest monologue i've i've
heard you do
this is
no longer a matter of
a skills gap or a few million people
unemployed and employers frustrated
because of the mismatch of skills this
is a matter of national security i think
because i think it goes right to
our identity
as a people you know when i started that
foundation microworks 13 years ago on
labor day we had record high
unemployment every single morning i woke
up i was shooting dirty jobs at the time
out in the world and i'd wake up and i'd
look at the headlines in the paper and
it was always
a click up right eight percent eight and
a half nine and so forth and so on but
everywhere we went on dirty jobs we we
saw help wanted signs and it became
obvious that something else was
happening in the country there was some
other
alternative narrative going on regarding
opportunity point is that was 13 years
ago and there were 2.3 open positions
2.3 million open positions today it's 11
million
11
million 12 million people quit their
jobs in the fall so you're right to
wonder what is going on and is there an
explanation that goes beyond
money
and the answer is yeah yeah it's a
it's our whole relationship with work
so
look
it it feels very political because
everything today is very political right
the skills gap shouldn't be though look
one quick point all my buddies on the
left
tell me that the reason for all this
opportunity is because employers are
fundamentally rapacious and greedy and
all my buddies on the right tell me all
of this opportunity is a function of
workers being universally lazy and
shiftless they're both painting with too
broad a brush the answers as you said
are a bit more complicated
i think that's exactly right but at its
heart is the question of national
character is this a country
that respects labor i don't mean
organized labor though maybe that too
but the actual labor the act of creating
something that didn't exist before the
act of improving something that was
broken like do we respect that
well
i think part of the fault in our stars
is that we come to resent the very
things we rely upon
so you know when the power goes out for
three or four days up here where i live
people shake their fists at the linemen
because they're frustrated but the
linemen are trying to get the power back
on so no we don't really respect it in
fact skilled labor all too often reminds
the rest of us of what we're
fundamentally lacking the thing that
scares me more than anything and the
reason i started the foundation when i
did was 13 years ago for every five
tradesmen that retired
two replace them
this is what abraham lincoln called a
terrible arithmetic and if that was the
only thing going on today we'd have
cause to be concerned but to your
earlier points it's not just the boomers
uh retiring earlier it is a it's a real
fear of covid that's been infecting us
it doesn't matter whether the fear is
justified or not it's there it's real
the class thing that you mentioned
whether it's true or not we've been told
that the reason we're unhappy is that
our bosses make too much and so forth
and so on it's a big complicated hairy
mess